Chris Pratt may be a big movie star now
not to mention an Avenger but in honor
of Chris's home both Hollywood
beginnings our Friday flashback is
dedicated to when we first met him did
it in an indent and it did did this I
shined College for a prestigious career
in door-to-door sales
I made national salesman of the year and
acquired a taste for rejection which
eventually led me to acting you're gonna
screw this whole thing up you realize
that right our first introduction to
Chris was on the set of Everwood we
quickly fell in love so back to my goals
as an actor me Chris Pratt to be quite
honest and to be blatantly real like
three months ago I was going out on
risky's commercials you know and now I'm
I booked this series and this is great
most inspirational award in high school
track my junior year so basically this
is just a walk in the park you notice
another thing I gotta do before finding
fame and Parks and Rec Chris was a
waiter at Bubba Gump shrimp and used to
live out of the van I wasn't lonely in
this van because I had I had roommates
so it's not as bad as it seems
oh look at that - this young boy full of
ambition naked on camera and having no
filter those are a few trademarks Pratt
is proud of oh and did we mention this
guy also knows how to braid hair start
with braiding the top one I don't have a
comb here it's all freestyle what can't
this guy do it's ridiculous
gosh this is not embarrassing at all but
what really caught our eye was when he
dropped almost 70 pounds for his
guardians of the galaxy role how to do
that yeah I haven't had beer basically
in the year 2013 was the full-time job
not drinking beer for me it's been
difficult for my wife - I think I'm a
jolly drunk so I think she has more fun
with me when I'm when I'm drinking beer
very sexy now it's all ripped but
very good very cuddly before which I
love yes
our belief in love was tested when Chris
and on affairs divorce but now he's
engaged to Katherine Swartz and Egger
what do we know about an I do date
here's what Chris told us back in 2011
you get engaged it's like let's pull it
off within a year the best piece of
relationship advice I've ever received
I've heard some people say don't go to
bed mad
I think that's garbage sometimes you got
to go to bed mad but at least touch the
toes and as for the secret to his
success well it's the same philosophy
the star shared back in 2002 when we
first met Chris Pratt
I want to never take life too seriously
and I want to always have fun and I want
to always make decisions that allow me
to do that I want to be a free spirit he
certainly is a very free spirit and a
great guy not to mention he's also a
part-time farmer Chris often post photos
of the animals he helps raise with help
from fiancee Katherine Schwarzenegger on
his 100 Acre property in Washington
[Music]
[Applause]